[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings uh we are
just about one day exactly believe it or
not 20 years uh since 9 11 a moment that
changed this country in a very big way
we're still feeling it we are still
feeling it we're going to talk about
those changes in this hour uh starting
with secretary of state former secretary
of state hillary clinton the background
of course 3 000 americans died on 9 11
more than that in fact
and on that day day after clinton
visited ground zero in manhattan it was
a year after she had just been sworn in
as new york's junior senator that was
just eight months earlier and on 9 11
she said that she hoped the catastrophe
would unite the entire civilized world
former secretary of state clinton joins
us now madam secretary good morning to
you
i think your hope for a united world
came true if only briefly and i want to
get to where we are today all these
years later
but let's stick with the memories for a
moment you were a new senator in
washington d.c on 9 11 when you think
back to that day what stands out to you
oh what stands out
is the
overwhelming sense of
devastation and tragedy
i was on my way to the senate for a
hearing about improving education
actually
laura bush was scheduled to testify when
uh the first plane hit and
after making sure that my
entire staff was safe and that they
could relocate
out of the
capital area so that we could begin
working
on i was on the phone endlessly talking
with elected officials in the state
obviously people in washington
and
looking at the television like every
american was glued to the scenes of
devastation
but i have to tell you that when i went
the next day
with my colleague senator schumer we
were the only plane in the sky other
than fighter jets that were keeping
cover over
new york and other parts of our country
we landed at laguardia we took a
helicopter and we circled over
ground zero
and i cannot imagine anything that
looked more like the gates of hell
i thought i'd be prepared because i'd
seen it on tv but the tv screen
contained it and
circling over it
was something that i think about and
will never forget
but then quickly we had to support our
first responders other emergency workers
who were running toward danger not away
from it we had to support
the families whose loved ones were
literally
lost and second
we had so much work to do and in a way
it kept me going
in the face of such overwhelming
tragedy and of course we were
concerned that there might be more
attacks elsewhere in our country
and really it's the people who i met
that i worked with
over those years and still today i was
interviewing some for my my podcast that
reminded me of the heroism and
determination and tenacity
and as you said the overwhelming sense
at that time was of unity uh and
it really was an incredible moment of
the country and the world coming
together
yeah madam secretary i don't think unity
would be a word that people use to
describe
america today or the world today those
attacks changed us in more ways than we
can enumerate if you had to pick one or
two
what are the biggest changes to our
country to the world because of what
happened on 9 11.
i think that
we have to keep in mind that we did have
unity then it means it's possible and i
would hate to give up on it
but clearly we were changed once you've
been attacked as we were
we made some smart moves some not so
smart moves to try to protect ourselves
and our friends and allies and people
across the globe
we also tried i think to show our spirit
of resolution and resilience and as a
senator from new york working to rebuild
lower manhattan i saw that every single
day how people picked themselves up
how people in the midst of incredible
grief and loss
figured out how they could keep going so
i keep almost this duality in mind
uh the tragedy the devastation the
attacks what we had to do in the
immediate aftermath some of the
decisions that were made but also the
way that it lifted us up and
i know we're in a really divided country
right now i understand that completely
but boy do i wish that we could be
reminded um of the courage and the
resilience and the tenacity and the
unity that we all experienced 20 years
ago
you know madam secretary we have a new
home here on times square and as
thrilled as i am to be here i admit i'm
a little nervous sometimes i'm looking
around more than i normally do
and i think a lot of americans are
concerned about a threat risk here in
the united states because of our
withdrawal from afghanistan do you share
those concerns
i think you always have to be uh
vigilant gail and and certainly that
unfortunately comes with living in the
world as we know it today but actually i
am more concerned about internal threats
we always have to be aware of and
protect against external threats but
what really is
tearing our country apart and
threatening our democracy is what we saw
on january 6th
and i
unfortunately have seen so much of that
kind of continuing divisiveness and
hatred and
ideological uh attitudes about our
democracy about each other
so yes we have to be constantly aware of
potential
damage attacks threats from outside
but i think every american regardless of
where you stand on the political
spectrum
should be as worried if not more right
now about what we're doing to ourselves
you know we can take anything we can we
can overcome anything we can come back
from anything if we're if we're united
but if we are going to continue to
uh hate each other uh scapegoat each
other
try to undermine each other go after our
institutions our voting system
uh yeah then we are putting ourselves at
great risk and that's what keeps me up
at night these days
yeah you raise a very good point already
there's discussion on whether we should
put the barbed wire back up at the
capitol people aren't thinking about
that for no reason yeah make a very good
point yeah and here we are one yeah one
day unfortunately we've got
yeah we've got we've got another um
gathering at the capitol that
is supposed to take place and
i guess next week and honestly
uh every fair-minded
american should should want the laws
enforced and protect our democracy
madam secretary you made a really good
point earlier about how 911 was so big
it was really bigger than tv but we're
doing our best here to memorialize it
today 20 years later thank you for
helping us in that effort
thank you thank you all